نبدا باصابه ثلاثين فلسطينيا على الاقل
بالرصاص المعدني المغلف بالمطاط وقنابل
الغاز وذلك خلال مواجهه اندلعت مع قوه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بلده جبل المكبر
وقد اقتحمت قوات كبيره من شرطه الاحتلال
وقوات حرس الحدود حيه ابشير في البلده
وطوقت المنطقه تمهيدا لهدم منزلين تعود
ملكيتهما لاحد المواطنين وهو ابراهيم بشير
وابنه ادهم وقد بدات جرافاته بلديه
الاحتلال بهدم المنزلين بذريعه عدم
الترخيص بينما تحصنت العائله وسكان من
الحي في المنزل الاخر لمنعه من الهدم
وتقوم قوه الاحتلال بقمع السكان باطلاق
الاعيره المعدنيه المغلفه بالمطاط وقنابل
الصوت والغاز
اصيب الزميل المصور في شبكه الجزيره
والسلايمه بعيار مطاطي في رجله اطلقه عليه
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هو ذلك خلال
تصويره عمليه هدم المنازل الفلسطينيه في
ضاحيه جبل المكبر في القدس المحتله
ظهر اليوم وقد نقل الزميل السلايمه الى
المستشفى لتلقي العلاج رغم عرقله قوات
الاحتلال وصول طاقم الاسعاف
ونقله لمستشفى
الان معنا من بلده جبل المكبر مراسلتنا
نجوان سمري اذا انت كنت بلا شك مرافقه
لوائل السلايمه الذي شهدناها قبل قليل وهو
مصاب ولكن في النهايه هذا هو يعني الديدان
في مثل هذه العمليات تطلق الاعيره الناريه
ولا يهم اذا كان هناك فريق اعلامي صحفي ام
مواطنين عاديين صفي لنا الاجواء عندك
نجوان
نعم بدايه ليله دعيني اطمئن بان الزميل
وائل السلايمه بخير الان وهو يتلقى العلاج
في مستشفى في القدس المحتله وتحدثنا اليه
عده مرات في الساعه الاخيره وهو بخير اصيب
في قدمه في ساقه بعيار مطاطي وهو الرصاص
المعدني المغلف بالمطاط تماما في هذا
الموقع حيث كنا نغطي عمليه هدم المنازل
لعائله بشير كنا مجموعه من الصحفيين نتحرك
سويا ولكن مع بدء انسحاب قوات الاحتلال
بعد ان انهت عمليه هدم ثلاثه منازل
للمواطنين الفلسطينيين في هذا الحي بداوا
يطلقون بشكل عشوائي الاعيره
المطاطيه والقنابل الغاز
وقنابل الصوت وايضا كان هناك اطلاق للرصاص
الحي ورغم اننا كنا كنا نقف جميعنا بشكل
بنفس الموقع كما اطقم صحفيه الا ان احد
الجبات العسكريه وبشكل متعمد قام باطلاق
قنابل الغاز باتجاه الطاقم الصحفيه بشكل
متعمد ومن ثم تم اطلاق اعييره معدنيه
مغلفه بالمطاط ما ادت الى اصابه الزميل
وائل السلايمه المعروف بالحج ابو داوود
ونتمنى له السلامه بطبيعه الحال قوات
الاحتلال كانت قد حاصرت هذا الحي منذ صباح
هذا اليوم وشرعت بعمليات هدم
للمواطن ابراهيم ابشير له
ولابنيه المتزوجين ثلاثه منازل تم هدمها
صباح هذا اليوم بعد ان تم ابلاغ العائله
في الايام الاخيره الماضيه عن نيه
الاحتلال لتنفيذ قرار بهجم عده منازل هنا
في هذا الحي وفي احياء اخرى في بلده جبل
المكبر بذريعه البناء دون ترخيص هناك
منازل عده اخرى مهدده
بالهدم وفي اعقاب عمليات الهدمنتال اندلعت
مواجهات في هذا الموقع بين الشبان
الفلسطينيين وبين قوات الاحتلال وبحسب
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني تجاوزت او تجاوز
عدد الاصابات الثلاثين اصابه هناك ايضا
مؤسسات طبيه اخرى كانت تتعامل مع اصابات
اختناق بالغاز المسيل بالدموع وبالايره
المطاطيه هناك خشيه في هذه البلده تحديدا
من التعرض للمنازل والاستهدافات المستمره
اذا اذا قوات الاحتلال تعود في هذه
الاثناء
ليلى رغم انها انسحبت قبل قليل اذا مره
اخرى قنابل الغاز وقنابل الصوت بالقرب منا
اطار اطار ابتعد هذه القنبلات غاز
[تصفيق]
اثار اذا قنبله غاز مره اخرى تطلق
باتجاهنا
رغم ان القوات انسحبت قبل نحو ساعه من هذا
الموقع الان تعود ومباشره كما رايتم
اطلاق لي قنبله غاز مسيل للدموع